bernard cazeneuve le ministre délégué
aux affaires européennes est l'invité de
preuve parfois bonsoir monsieur le
ministre on soir merci d'être avec nous
le climat se tend autour de la
ratification du traité européen à la
gauche se divise françois hollande aura
besoin des voix de la droite vous ne
ménagez pas votre peine je crois depuis
des semaines jour après jour chaque
heure de la journée presque pour
convaincre de la nécessité d'adopter ce
texte synonyme pour ses détracteurs à la
gauche de la gauche de camisole de
rigueur de souffrance des peuples
entendons également qu'en un quart
d'heure hervé hasquin qui si l'elysée
pour l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire vous interrogera sur
les difficultés économiques qui entraîne
bien sûr celle du pouvoir exécutif avec
ce trou d'air qui se confirme dans les
sondages
troisième partie avec perrine tarneaud
de public sénat et laon l'ignorent mais
vous avez une complicité de 20 ans avec
françois hollande nous en parlerons tout
à l'heure les téléspectateurs peuvent
intervenir durant cette émission par le
biais de l'application tvcheck de notre
autre partenaire avec la sp orange le
traité budgétaire donc d'abord et sa
règle d'or qui sont examinées ce
mercredi au conseil des ministres
françois hollande n'en voulait pas dans
l'opposition on s'en souvient il accepte
désormais au pouvoir grâce au pacte de
croissance qui a été ajoutée mais mais
monsieur le ministre la majorité
n'échappera pas à la discorde
il est normal que sont les questions de
l'europe il y ait un débat à gauche le
débat sur l'europe c'est consubstantiel
au fonctionnement de nos familles
politiques il a toujours existé et je
pense que nous aurions tort d'ailleurs
de vouloir l'éviter il faut l'assumer
il faut le conduire il faut aller au
devant de ceux qui peuvent avoir des
opinions diverses sur ce sujet essayer
de répondre à leurs interrogations
c'est ce que je m'emploie à faire depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines en étant
la disposition des parlementaires des
responsables d'organisations politiques
avec le souci d'expliquer quelle est la
politique européenne du gouvernement qui
doivent bien au delà de ce traité qui
est un élément recontextualiser 2
d'essayer d'apporter tous les éléments
de réponse avec la plus grande des
bougies je crois qu'il ya titre
rigoureusement connaître sur tout ce qui
viendra après on attend surtout les
opposants aujourd'hui les présidents des
groupes écologiques par exemple au
parlement qui disent on va voter non à
part le front on entend le front de
gauche jean luc mélenchon qui dit il
faut un référendum
plusieurs éléments de réponses d'abord
qu'est ce que nous avions dit en dans la
campagne présidentielle nous avions dit
nous ne voulons pas à s'offrir la règle
d'or dans la constitution le conseil
constitutionnel nous a donné raison
alors que le précédent pouvoir rouler à
la sauvette rapidement faire en sorte
qu'on inscrive cette règle dans la
constitution deuxièmement nous avions
dit nous voulons réorienter profonde et
malartic devenir l'on m'avait lille ont
renégocié réguler ont réorienté
profondément la politique de l'union
européenne et faire en sorte qu'à côté
des disciplines budgétaires dont nous
avons besoin pour rétablir nos comptes
il y vraiment des initiatives pour la
croissance dans l'avion dit aux anges
après nous avions dit aussi qu'il
fallait remettre de l'ordre dans la
finance et qu'il fallait plus de
solidarité
au regard de ses engagements qu'avons
nous obtenu nous avons obtenu un impact
pour la croissance de 140 milliards
d'euros 120 milliards d'euros de
mobilisation de fonds européens public
qui appelle 120 milliards d'euros
d'investissements privés par effet de
levier
ça permettra de faire de la croissance
durable de la transition énergétique de
financer les grands investissements dans
l'europe a besoin deuxièmement nous
avions dit nous voulons remettre de
l'ordre dans la finance
c'est un combat historique de la gauche
nous avons sur le métier la supervision
bancaire
nous voulons aller au delà avec un
dispositif de résolution des crises
bancaires de garantie des dépôts gay
nous avions dit le terrain par là c'est
important nous voulons que les peuples
d'europe ne soient pas confrontées à
l'austérité à perte de vue et pour cela
il nous paraît indispensable que ce ne
soit pas les états qui financent sur les
marchés à des conditions de taux très
contraignantes pour eux la
recapitalisation des banques
nous avons le mécanisme européen de
stabilité qui permet de recapitaliser
les banques et qui évitera ainsi que les
états n'aient à le faire en ayant là que
le marché est en reparler dans la
facture sur les peuples se veut dire
concrètement quoi ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui à travers la croissance la
remise en ordre de la finance
et à travers la solidarité le ms
l'europe et a écrit un opéra rock a été
profondément relais mais pas le parent
négocier au niveau du traité salle il
faut le dire c'était une erreur de le
dire dans la campagne
non je n'en longe l'argumentation nous
nous avions un traité dont la règle d'or
devait être inscrit dans la constitution
et qui était considérée par le précédent
pouvoir comme l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique de l'union pas d'autre horizon
possible
nous nous avons aujourd'hui la
discipline budgétaire n'est pas dans la
constitution
elle fera l'objet d'une loi votée à la
majorité aux arrêts et il y aura le
rétablissement des comptes publics parce
que c'était un engagement de campagne et
à côté il y à la croissance la remise en
ordre de la finance des maîtres des
mécanismes de solidarité renforcée pour
faire en sorte que la politique de
l'union européenne soit profondément
réoriente alors moi qui ai voté non en
2005 contre le travailleur qui engage l
europe dans une pente libéral qui
empêché l'europe d'avoir les moyens de
réorienter sa politique
aujourd'hui je suis mise un gouvernement
qui procède à une réorientation profonde
de la politique de l'union européenne et
on ne peut pas et lors que dans
l'adversité face à des gouvernements
conservateurs face aux marchés qu'ils
attaquent les états en encourageant
parfois la spéculation ne pas considérer
qu'il est positive de mettre en oeuvre
ce pourquoi on s'est battus quand vous
en valeur avec financière par exemple
doit permettre aussi de doter le budget
du management tout ça n'est pas rien
quand ça n'est pas rien aux arguments
sont très rodé ce qu'admet vont vous
écoute on les entend on reçoit vos
arguments 6 mai alors j'en sors vraiment
arguments d'esbrouffe heures
d'enseignement pressent afrique et les
deux groupes une personne en particulier
mais je dis que sur un sujet de ce type
là il faut être précis rigoureux qu'il
ya des chaleurs et louis mais le
regarder du côté communiste pierre
laurent dit ne pas ratifier s'est donné
une deuxième chance à sa renégociation
et puis le front de gauche cherche à
mobiliser on le sait avec une
manifestation le 30 septembre et ce
qu'elle vous inquiète jeudi à pierre
laurent qui développe l'idée qu'il
pourrait y avoir une renégociation de ce
traité dans un contexte très différent
de celui qui prévalait en juin
ce que depuis juin nous avons obtenu
tout ce que je viens de bellion va fait
que des pays ont ratifié et que ce
traité entre en vigueur dès lors que
douze pays ont procédé à sa ratification
même s'il n'a pas été ratifié par
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne que tellement il est demandé
jeudi à monsieur laurent que demander ça
aujourd'hui c'est à dire bloquer le
fonctionnement d'une institution
européenne
c'est bloquer les mécanismes de
solidarité mis en oeuvre en faveur des
pays qui souffrent c'est accélérer le
paiement de la facture du redressement
de l'économie par les peuples s'est
ajouté une couche de crise politique à
la crise financière à la crise monétaire
la crise profonde qui vous aidera le
mélange en août et de la crise à la
crise par ce surtout lorsque l'on a
obtenu une première étape qui en appelle
d'autres
on suppose que dans l'europe nous
gardions notre force et le traitement et
que dix voix jean-luc mélenchon c'est un
peu l'âme la mecque genre mais qui dit
lui c'est notre devoir de réclamer un
référendum ou d'ailleurs marqué qu'une
très grande majorité françaises sont
favorables au référendum y atteindre
oui je réponds une chose précise anne en
laye mélenchon 7
ces dispositions que nous allons
entériné au parlement sont des
dispositions qui font l'objet d'une
procédure les six têtes qui qu'ordinaire
être adoptés n'ont pas la majorité
qualifiée mais à la majorité des
suffrages exprimés et nous avons évité
que ce soit à ce que dans la concision
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'abandon de
souveraineté il ya beaucoup de sujets
sur lesquels aujourd'hui les français
pourraient demander un référendum et qui
relèvent non pas du transformation d'une
évolution de la constitution et de
processus législatif ordinaire nous
allons transformer la démocratie
française dans un système de césarisme
démocratique nous allons appeler au
référendum sur tous les sujets il ya
bien des sujets sur lesquels monsieur
mélenchon pourrait constater qu'il a une
demande des français je ne pourrais pas
et qui lui-même souhaiterait que ces
textes ne soient pas soumis au
référendum parce qu'il ya un moment où
la démocratie représentative doit
pouvoir jouer donc nous ne sommes pas
engagés sur l'organisation d'un
référendum
il n'y a pas une modification de la
constitution nous avons dit que nous
présenterions ce texte à la délibération
parlementaire si la plainte de l'union
européenne étaient réorientés
nous faisons ce camp nous nous sommes
engagés
manifestation mais pas répondu la
manifestation appelée par par le front
de gauche de 37 ans beaucoup de choses à
vous inquiet parce que ça va être le
poids de toutes les frustrations et des
impatiences au delà du traité européen
mais on ne bâtit pas une politique en
exploitant les frustrations des
inquiétudes ont conduit une politique en
ayant le courage en essayant de faire en
sorte que cette politique répondant à
l'intérêt général du pays répondent à
l'intérêt général de l'union européenne
moi je comprends parfaitement
l'inquiétude de ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont victimes de la crise qui
s'inquiètent de l'avoir senti c'est
précisément parce que je comprends cette
inquiétude là que par respect par
conception de ce que doit être l'action
politique lorsqu'on est face à des défis
aussi important on ne doit pas exploiter
cela en détournant le vote son objet
vous les dossiers certains
parlementaires socialistes qui ne trompe
pas voter ce traité
chacun est libre de moi je ne suis pas
leur part déjà merci à la droite saka
sait ce qu'il doit faire
en conscience je dis simplement que
bonheur merci non mais je voudrais
d'abord m'adresser à ceux dont vous
parliez à l'instant c'est à dire tous
ceux qui à gauche s'interroge et
s'apprête à émettre compter la vente ne
soit pas un ado soutient réjean parent
d'enfant ayant mettre d'accord et je le
redis nous sommes dans une situation de
combat
nous avons en face de nous de multiples
fronts un président de la république est
engagé dans la réorientation de l'europe
plutôt que de lui compliquer la tâche
en l'empêchant d'avoir avec les toutes
les dynamiques qui lui permettrait
d'aller plus loin
si vous voulez que le président de la
république réussissent à mettre en
oeuvre ce que vous désirez ne rendez pas
ce que vous désirez impossible en
compliquant la tâche mais peut-être que
certains contestataires au front de
gauche n'ont pas envie qu'ils
réussissent à une autre question demande
est là vous dites déjà merci à la droite
qui va permettre à françois hollande
j'ai bien mais moi j'en aurais tu aimé
moi je trouve que c'est d'ailleurs aussi
un message que vous m'aider à envoyer à
tous à toute la gauche serait qu'il
légitime et normal après que un
gouvernement
à présent la république avec toutes les
forces qui les ont portés au pouvoir
s'engage dans la réorientation de
l'europe qu'on laisse ce plaisir à la
droite qui s'est opposé à cette
orientation qui nous a expliqué qu'elle
était impossible
d'arracher une victoire qu'elle ne
mérite pas et dont nous aurions bien
besoin pour pouvoir aller plus loin dans
la réorientation d'europe parce qu est
ce qu il faut comprendre à l affaire
c'est que si nous voulons réussir la
réorientation de l'ordre au delà de ce
que nous avons obtenu
nous avons besoin d'avoir de la force
tout le monde regarde la france en
europe ce pays si l'on se rend pas c'est
parce que nous avons obtenu de haute
lutte et contestés par ceux qui l'on
demandait à nos côtés qui sont censés
nous soutenir alors vous seront plus
faibles donc vous dites les nouvelles
résines eu un risque de perte d'autorité
de françois hollande en europe le risque
l'arno je ne dis pas ça je dis qu'il ya
déjà là je ne dis pas ça je dis qu'il ya
une perte de force et nécessité pour un
gouvernement qui se bat afin d'obtenir
la réorientation d'une politique et
qu'il obtient pour partie est ici qu'il
a devant lui d'autres facteurs d'avoir
toute sa majorité avec lui pour que ces
autres étapes soient franchies dans les
meilleures conditions c'est assez
cohérent prévu avant on a compris deux
petites questions rapides avant de
parler situation économique et sociale
un mot d'abord sur la question des roms
vous avez accompagné il ya quelques
jours manuel valls en roumanie est ce
que la question de l'aide au retour est
posée il a une prime de 100 euros par
adulte qui est donné on connaissait les
effets pervers de remettre en cause oui
ou non c'est une décision qui doit être
prise par le gouvernement dans son
ensemble et qui ne dépend pas de la
compétence des européennes mais nous
avons entendu avec manuel valls des
critiques concernant cette mesure et son
inefficacité et manuel valls a indiqué à
la presse en roumanie que ce sujet
serait examinée expertise est une sas
est ce que vous êtes choqués par les
nouvelles caricatures de mahomet en
pages intérieures de charlie hebdo le
prix dans le présent la république et le
premier ministre à nice notamment se
sont exprimés sur ce sujet liberté
d'expression laïcité responsabilité les
matches des occasions mais la liberté de
la page n'est pas une provocation rien à
ajouter on avait un super fait de la
presse laïcité responsabilité hervé
hasquin de l' agence france-presse donc
va nous rejoindre pour évoquer les
difficultés qu'affrontent pouvoir la
crise la chute dans les sondages
voyons d'abord comment la progression de
la courbe du chômage
avant de s'inverser dans un an a annoncé
le chef de l'état continue à sombrer la
situation à pied le moral de tous les
français
mounir saucisses psa doux et bientôt
peut-être sanofi les plans sociaux se
suivent et le gouvernement peine à
contenir l'hémorragie
le président a beau se mettre en
première ligne la crise est plus forte
il ne pourra pas se battre sur tous les
fronts inversée en une année la courbe
du chômage tout en ramenant le déficit à
3% du pib
deux objectifs affichés concertée à une
situation économique dégradée
malheureusement il ya un choix à faire
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas à la fois
réduire drastiquement les déficits
publics c'est à dire mener des plans
d'austérité de grande ampleur tout en
réduisant le chômage sont globalement si
on mène une politique d'austérité de
cette ampleur on aura au mieux très peu
de croissance
au pire une récession tenus par les
obligations européennes de réduction des
déficits françois hollande choisi le
camp de l'austérité avec son plan
d'action et son calendrier détaillé il
cherche à fixer un cap
le président dit entrer dans une phase
d'accélération de ces réformes mais à
france at elle les moyens de suivre wac
les marges de manoeuvre sont extrêmement
réduites on voit que d'ailleurs le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il peut avec le
peu de moyens qu'il a assez rare que
mettre en place des emplois d'avenir le
contrat génération c'est plutôt des
choses qui sont positives pour mâcher le
travail mais on voit bien que c'est
plutôt des mesures qui viennent en
urgence des difficultés qui se
traduisent dans les enquêtes d'opinion
après un été hésitant et la mise en
scène d'une entrée énergique l'exécutif
poursuit sa chute dans les sondages
la récente reprise en main n'a pour
l'instant aucun effet il ya aujourd'hui
la volonté la part des français d'avoir
l'institut d'analysé présent qui donne
le sentiment que le politique à une
prise sur l'économique et qu'il ouvre
des perspectives
la promesse de campagne de réenchanter
le rêve français sera difficile à tenir
avec des prévisions de croissance revues
à la baisse c'est bien la réalité des
chiffres qui va fixer le cap du
gouvernement
voilà hervé hasquin de l' agence
france-presse
avec nous c'est le correspondant de
l'agencé à l'elysée bonsoir hervé votre
question à bernard cazeneuve
bien la question du jour c'est cette la
tva et la csg
le point affirmait que jean marc ayrault
pour s asseoir sur un engagement très
fort du gouvernement est décidé une
hausse finalement d'un tva s'est
démentie ce soir par matignon qui
démarre en à la fois là-haut csg et de
la tv alors qu'est ce que vous allez
faire comment redresser les finances la
france
comment lutter contre le déficit sans
augmenter ni l'un ni l'autre
la réponse à cette question est apporté
par françois hollande à l'occasion de
ces expressions récentes notamment il ya
de cela une dizaine de jours interrogé
par un de vos confrères une de vos
confrères sur une autre chaîne
nous devons rétablir les comptes publics
c'est un engagement que nous avons pris
nous devons le faire pour des raisons
assez simple la dette
caubère notre souveraineté détérioration
continue de comptes publics au cours des
dix dernières années
induit des taux d'intérêt sur les
marchés qui rendent impossible la
croissance parce que ceux qui peuvent
faire la croissance qui investissent
sont confrontés à des taux d'intérêt qui
obère les chances d'investir dans des
conditions efficace économiquement et
par conséquent le rétablissement des
comptes publics sur lequel nous sommes
engagés
c'est une nécessité en termes de
souveraineté c'est un devoir que nous
avons vis à vis des générations futures
et c'est une décision c'est un
engagement d'efficacité l'allégeance et
comment elle arrive
le président de la république a indiqué
qu'elle était la méthode il a indiqué
qu'il y aurait d'abord des efforts faits
de maîtrise des dépenses publiques dans
l'appareil dédiant 10 milliards oui 10
milliards de maîtrise 6 alençon du
verdict lever 1 milliard 20 milliard de
recettes supplémentaires parce qu'alors
willow mais je vous rappelle que la
trajectoire de finances publiques
présenté par le précédent gouvernement
devant les institutions de bruxelles
puisque depuis le six pack nous sommes
obligés désormais de présenter une
trajectoire de finances publiques
savez-vous quels étaient les engagements
du précédent gouvernement soit on parle
jamais il serait intéressant de comparer
ce que nous faisons par rapport à ce que
se proposait de faire les autres parce
que c'est à ça qu'on mesure d'apporter
d'une réorientation politique et d'une
alternance connaissez vous ces chiffres
ici alors je vous les donne ces chiffres
c'était 11 milliards de diminution
des dépenses de l'état c'était 15
milliards de prélèvement fiscal auquel
s'ajoutait 13 milliards de prélèvements
à travers la tva sociale c'est à dire 28
milliards de prélèvements et 11
milliards d'économies avec monsieur
ascain une prévision de croissance qui
était de 1,4 pour cent nous nous sommes
à une période prévision de croissance
beaucoup plus réaliste de 0,8 et nous
avons la volonté de faire en sorte que
les économies budgétaires que nous
devons afficher parce que nous ne
pouvons pas rétablir les consignes ne
faisons pas un effort de maîtrise de nos
dépenses 10 milliards et puis
effectivement des prélèvements mais
alors ces prélèvements sont des
prélèvements qui se font dans la volonté
de faire en sorte que les plus riches
des contributeurs français soit appelée
à contribution pendant la période de
redressement de manière à faire en sorte
que ce ne soient pas les plus modestes
et plus faible des français qu'ils
soient appelés à faire un effort de
redressement bien c'est à dire et c'est
la politique fiscale inverse de celle
qui a été menée au cours des cinq
dernière mais alors vous peinez à à
convaincre les français le patronat
attaquer les retraités sont inquiets
le le prix du gas qui devait augmenter
selon le rythme d'inflation au plus cela
finalement augmenté bien plus vite
est ce que la crise vous a pris de court
est ce que vous êtes surpris vous savez
à quoi vous attendre pourtant les
français sont inquiets comment ne le
serait-il pas voilà un gouvernement qui
est en situation d'exercer entretenu
autres d'un certain déni mais je réponds
à la question comment on ne le serait-il
pas et je répondrai également à votre
interpellation de l'est de l'instant
voilà un pays qui a été gouverné pendant
dix ans à la même sensibilité politique
600 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
au cours des cinq années qui viennent de
s'écouler une augmentation record du
déficit une dégradation de notre
compétitivité dont témoigne
l'aggravation du déficit du commerce
extérieur 75 milliards d'euros
un chômage qui a augmenté de 1 million
de personnes au cours du dernier
quinquennat et nous trouvons la france
dans cette situation d'inquiétude avec
une europe qui peine à trouver le chemin
une réponse rapide dans l'urgence aux
défis que chaque jour lui envoie la
crise et nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation où nous prenons le pays
dans ce contexte est ce que nous avons
sous faisait la nuit la crise jamais
fêtés porte parole de françois hollande
pendant la campagne présidentielle
je les accompagne et dans beaucoup de
déplacements en province et beaucoup de
déplacements où il allait aux rencontres
à la rencontre des français qui étaient
à quai jamais nous n'avons ni la crise
je me souviens du discours du bourget ou
françois hollande
prévenez de l'importance de l'effort
qu'ils seraient d'affaires et en même
temps ce qui ne marche pas et en même
temps les additions que tout cela
devrait se faire dans la juridiction qui
ne marche pas il y a pour une raison
d'âge sont si mozart et les sondages
sont mauvais parce qu'il ya une période
de crise qui inquiète les français
et lorsqu'on est en situation de
responsabilité politique dans une
période de crise aussi profonde et qu'on
doit prendre des décisions aussi
difficiles que celles que nous prenons
ça ne peut pas conduire avant que le
redressement est fait son oeuvre à une
irrépressible popularité dizaine
toujours le coz et d'ambré venu
télévision pour essayer justement de
renverser l'opinion pour dire voilà nous
sommes à la tâche le gouvernement indien
et le président de la république
tunisienne est venu à la télévision pour
dire je vais renverser l'opinion c'est
vous qui interprété les raisons pour
lesquelles que l'objectif ait trouvé la
confiance dans le progrès la frapper
dans la déclaration du président de la
république c'est quelque chose qui
évoquait en moi ce que j'entendais chez
pierre mendès france lorsque la france
était confrontée à une crise d'une autre
nature et que le pouvoir devait y faire
face
en sachant qu'ils affronteraient bien
les difficultés le président de la
république a dit seulement une situation
difficile j'ai indiqué que j'engagerai
une politique de redressement dans la
justice je le fais et je le fais en
disant comment je le fais à partir de
quel calendrier et je vous indique que
je vous rendrai compte étape par étape
les décisions que je prends des sujets
que je ne sur le métier pour faire en
sorte que la crise soit surmontée
le président de la république il est
allé devant les français n'ont pas pour
le séduire non pas pour redresser je ne
sais quel courbe des sondages est allée
devant les français pour leur dire j'ai
pris des engagements
je suis en situation de responsabilité
dans une période de crise extrêmement
grave
j'entends tenir mes engagements mon
calendrier et vous rendre tout ça suffit
est-ce que ça suffit pour retrouver les
français pour retrouver ce contact avec
les français il ya une sorte de désamour
qui s'exprime dans les sondages parce
que ça vous agace nous dit c'est normal
la situation de crise est ce que ça vous
je ne dis pas que une autre situation
mais qui n'a jamais imaginé que ça vous
êtes dans la crise alors que nous
prenons des décisions difficiles nous
puissions malgré tout cela et
contrairement à ce qui se produit dans
l'ensemble des autres pays où des
gouvernements sont à la peine nous
soyons confrontés à des courbes de
popularité absolument inouïe bon ce
serait étonnant
pourrions nous interroger sur les
raisons pour lesquelles nous bénéficions
d'une situation tout aussi inédit que
les noirs avaient la solde du pouvoir
exécutif ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
que face à ces crises dont les français
ont conscience nous prenions des
décisions qui témoigne de la volonté que
nous avons deux d'assurer le
redressement et surtout et j'insiste sur
ce point de faire en sorte que le chemin
du redressement de selouane jamais d'un
objectif la justice et voilà allez on
adore mais là vous vous dites la justice
mais par exemple françois fillon lui
vous reprochent de n'avoir engagé aucune
réforme de structure quelles sont les
réformes de structures qui ont été
engagées quelques répondez-vous à
l'ancien premier ministre mais l'ancien
premier ministre se féliciter d'avoir
engagé des réformes de structures sous
le précédent quinquennat qui étaient des
réformes à justice fiscale et sociale la
droite considère que ne peut être
qualifiée de réforme de structure que
des réformes et entretiennent dans les
pays de l'injustice sociale et fiscale
et d'ailleurs ils ont été jusqu'à
organisé en catimini à la fin de la
législature dans la précipitation la
plus grande qui ressemblait à
l'improvisation la plus totale
la tva sociale comme si on pouvait en
trois mois régler des problèmes de
compétitivité qu'on a
les secours arrivés problème du chômage
en un an nous avons dit que nous
engagerions des réformes de structure
quelles sont ces réformes jouer dur hein
nous voulons créer les conditions de
dispositifs fiscaux qui encourage
l'investissement qui encourage
l'investissement dans l'appareil
productif qui encourage l'innovation et
le transfert de technologies plutôt que
la spéculation
les placements financiers ou toute autre
opération à laquelle les entreprises
sont tentées de se livrer lorsqu'elle pc
spécule plutôt que d'investir c'est la
réforme de l'impôt sur les sociétés
dentelle alors d'arrêter maintenant
c'est l'alignement de la fiscalité du
capital sur la fiscalité du travail
parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison non plus
que ceux qui travaillent soient
davantage fiscalisés que ceux qui
spéculent qui comme disait françois
mitterrand gagnent leur argent en
dormant donc nous sommes dans une
réforme profonde du 10 de la fiscalité
qui se fera par étapes comme l'indiqué
le premier ministre et père de la
république pour faire en sorte que
l'investissement l'appareil productif
soient favorisés deuxièmement nous avons
besoin dans ce pays d'organiser des de
mettre en oeuvre des politiques de
structures qui permettent de favoriser
la compétitivité de nos entreprises ne
peux pas rester avec un tel déficit du
commerce extérieur et nous ne pourrons
pas redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat
demain si nous n'avons pas une économie
compétitive qui contribuent à
l'enrichissement du pays ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire un des formations pour
les ressources humaines y compris pour
ceux qui sont les plus d insérer parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison qu'on laisse
quiconque sur le bord du marché du
travail et la ressource humaine dans
l'entreprise lorsqu'elle est bien formée
et qu'on met en place des politiques
pour atteindre cet objectif c'est une
richesse qui fait de la compétitivité et
on sent le moisi d'angola raisonnement
qui attendait le permis je vais est par
ailleurs leur exemplarité
le président de la république indiqué
qu'ils auraient deux réformes de
structure davantage de sécurité dans les
parcours professionnels
en contrepartie de quoi il pourrait y
avoir plus de souplesse et a renvoyé sa
à la discussion entre les partenaires
sociaux avec une volonté de prendre une
décision à la fin d'année et par
ailleurs
il a indiqué que la question du coût du
travail et de la protection sociale
serait mis sur le métier comme un
élément qu'il faut traiter entre les
partenaires sociaux pour décider et le
président de la république a aussi
indiqué qu'à la fin de l'année au terme
de la discussion entre les acteurs
sociaux nous prendrions nos
responsabilités ça nous l'allons lourds
ont fait en six mois alors des choses
qui dit que tout le monde observe avec
beaucoup d'attention c'est la cohésion
de ce gouvernement
elle a été un peu mise à mal ces
derniers temps et encore aujourd'hui ces
derniers jours sur le vote des étrangers
la question et a ressurgi il ya des
ministres qui disait c'est pas une
urgence un manuel valls s'est pas eu
trop de passion majeure des français
d'autres qui disent il faut le faire
tout de suite
alors d'abord il faut le faire quand et
puis bon c'est comme annoncé c'est un
nouveau cafouillage le gouvernement
peine à trouver ses marques jean marc
ayrault un manque d'autorité
moi si vous voulez la meilleure manière
de ne pas rajouter une strate de débat
ou de polémique
ce que vous appelez de la confusion sur
des sujets aussi délicats ce qui honore
non ça veut dire tout simplement que
quand on est ministre dans un
gouvernement on s'exprime sur les sujets
qui relèvent de sa compétence
et quand on ne s'exprime pas sur les
sujets qui relèvent de sa compétence
ce qui n'est absolument pas interdit
quant au sujet n'a pas été arbitré on le
fait autour de la table du conseil des
ministres avant que la décision soit
prise pour concourir à la prise de la
bonne décision et on le fait
publiquement quand la décision est prise
et arbitrée par conséquent suhescun six
mois je vais m'exprimer sur cette
question là je le ferais autour de la
table du conseil des ministres pour
favoriser un arbitrage qui ira dans le
sens de ce que je souhaite
une fois que la décision aura été prise
je l'assumerai jeu la commenterai mais
on ne peut pas dans une période aussi
difficile être gouvernement en y allant
chacun de son côté lancé par conséquent
je ne le ferai pas moi même devant vous
non bien entendu vous avez bien entendu
c'est surtout un tempérament ils ne
feront certainement pas cette fois une
l'état j'estime que quand on est
ministre dans un gouvernement on
participent à la délibération collective
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres
une fois que la délibération collective
a eu lieu il ya deux solutions on est
content on assume aurès on n'est pas
content éventuellement on peut partir
c'est ce qu'ont fait d'autres comme jean
ferrat marie périer quoi je me plais
mais dans tout gouvernement il y à des
ajustements il ya des débats j'estime
que ma conception de la politique ma
conception du rôle de ministre
mon éthique dans l'exercice de ma
responsabilité gouvernementale me
conduit à ne pas me livrer devant vous à
ce jeu que je trouve inutile en faveur
qu'on n'a pas besoin de vous rappeler
les évidences effectivement mais
françois dans ma vie de le faire
effectivement sur tf1 il n'a pas été
entendu parce qu'il avait dit c'est la
fin des couacs et y en a encore eu
effectivement avec ces divergences au
sein du gouvernement
publiquement exprimé dernière question
de la question une question très
européenne qui vous concerne le premier
chef cette affaire de fusion eads à eux
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour l'europe
le spécialiste de la défense puisque
mais la question c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'europe ce pourrait être
une bonne nouvelle crée un mastodonte
face à boeing
avec le poids nécessaire ça pourrait
être une bonne nouvelle pour le
rappelait pourtant on sent que paris et
même vers lens sont réticents qu'est ce
qui gêne qu'est ce qui vous gêne le le
questionnement sur ce sujet c'est un
questionnement techniques
essentiellement parce que les deux
groupes sont deux groupes qui ont des
spécialités en matière d'activités
industrielles très différent qu'il y a
un groupe qui est très centrée sur la
défense b a eu un groupe qui s'est
beaucoup orientée vers les activités
civiles
eads il ya pour chacun de ces deux
groupes européens des relations de
partenariat qui existe sur des sujets
stratégiques avec des groupes qui ne
sont pas européens et par conséquent
énormément d'obstacles techniques à
lever ici on n'aimait pas immédiatement
en ligne de mire risque de bloquer
l'opération de refouler les perspectives
sinon on fait pas on fait pas d'effusion
pour garder une base industrielle avec
pour premier objectif de réduire le
niveau des emplois et des entreprises
industrielles sur le territoire européen
ce n'est pas le sujet en l'occurrence
qui me préoccupe sur cette affaire là ce
qui me préoccupe c'est la dimension
technique qui justifierait presque d'une
émission particulière aux dirigeants moi
je veux bien rester à pourra l'entendre
qui peut justifier un moment donné qu'on
prenne des précautions pour assurer le
mariage entre un groupe très spécialisés
dans les affaires de défense est un
groupe qui s'est ouvert à des activités
civiles valeur n'est en revanche le
regroupement nos industries de l'essence
pour avoir une base industrielle de
défense qui en europe permettent de
faire face à la concurrence
internationale est une nécessité dès
lors qu'on veut avoir une politique
européenne de sécurité et de décence
pertinente très bien voilà merci
hervé paternot arrive monsieur le
ministre juste après cette enquête
d'alexandrie colinot bien sûr vous sur
votre parcours un proche à la fois
pendant des années des décennies même de
laurent fabius est de françois hollande
mais comment est ce que vous avez fait
s'il ya un nom sur qui personne n'aurait
parié au ministère des affaires
européennes
c'est bien le sien bernard cazeneuve le
moins europhile de tous celui qui a dit
non au référendum de 2005 puis au traité
de lisbonne en 2008
nul n'aurait misé non plus sur sa
nomination comme porte parole de la
campagne de françois hollande lui le
fidèle fabusien mais l'homme est aussi
là ni deux un temps du président cet
avocat discret donc un paradoxe un lien
entre deux courants puis tous trait
d'union pourrait être une belle
définition si ça ne faisait pas quelque
chose d'invertébrés
le quinquagénaire confesse volontiers sa
timidité maladive
mais ce titre est tenace preuve en est
son acharnement dans la sphère de
l'attentât de karachi rapporteur de la
mission d'information
il avance la thèse des rétrocommissions
malaise à l'assemblée calcul oui ou non
monsieur premier ministre un système de
commissions adossé à ce contrat et si
oui à qui ces commissions ont elles
bénéficié
deux ans plus tard étant à nouveau
d'obtenir des réponses sur ce dossier
secret défense
esclandre dans l'hémicycle bernard
cazeneuve a été le rapporteur de la
mission d'information parlementaire sur
la sphère de karachi
je leur ai fait tout pour s'exprimer
devant l'assemblée nationale
on retrouverait que m'ont mise à nue
agit en partisans ump et non en
président de la représentation d'un seul
la consultation
aujourd'hui celui qui a pour devise ne
pas hésiter à déplaire si c'est utile à
la tâche délicate séduire les députés de
sa propre majorité
réfractaire au traité européen de
stabilité
quelqu'un qui votent pas le mécanisme
européen sabilité puis ensuite qu'ils
défendent et qu'il le fait avec la même
conviction jeu j'emploie le terme
d'habileté habile avec eux serait
pourtant repéré un bon soir habileté oui
dit jean leonetti pour pas dire retourné
sa veste peut-être non mais moi je ne
rentre pas dans ce type de
considérations qui correspondent
d'ailleurs absolument pas à la manière
dont je fais de la politique et la
manière dont je m'engage en réalité 2005
le ms dont il parle est aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est une cohérence en 2005 voulions
une autre europe
cette autre europe nous sommes en train
de la faire au moment du vote sur le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
nous sommes abstenus n'avons pas voté
contre pourquoi parce qu'il existait un
lien entre le mécanisme européen de
stabilité dans les textes qui nous était
présentée et le traité qu'on nous
présentait comme l'horizon unique et
indispensable de la politique de l'union
européenne
aujourd'hui nous avons donné à la union
européenne un autre horizon
nous essayons de faire en sorte que nous
puissions avoir de la croissance de la
solidarité des mécanismes de stabilité
renforcée nous essayons de faire en
sorte que l'europe est une politique
industrielle et qu'elle s'engage sur le
chemin du développement durable qu'elles
permettent de faire en sorte que le
mécanisme inter d'interconnexion
européens soient financés à travers un
grand projet donc c'est tout cela que
nous essayons de faire et moi je suis
dans la cohérence qui ne sont pas dans
la cohérence sont ceux qui ont voulu en
2005 une réorientation de la politique
de l'union européenne et qui
n'accompagne pas lorsqu'elle devient
possible se font ce qu'ils voulaient une
europe exclusivement punitive avec des
disciplines budgétaires sans croissance
qui nous
expliqué que la croissance n'était pas
possible et qui dès lors qu'on l'obtient
explique qu'elle était dans les tuyaux
c'est là c'est la cohérence sur vos
convictions européennes dans les
capitales antenne quand vous avez été
nommé au vu de votre parcours de votre
double non à la fois en 2005 et au
traité de lisbonne également également
au vu du parcours de laurent blanc je
n'ai pas eu à voter je n'étais pas
député oui mais engagée oui d'accord
mais je n'ai pas voté mon moment du
traité lisbonne n'était pas dépité je
n'ai pas eu à le faire mais en revanche
j'ai voté effectivement sur le traité
constitutionnel en 2005 non j'ai voté
donc pourquoi j'ai senti la domination
certaine réticence dans lesquelles leur
mission j'ai senti bien entendu les
interrogations sur le fait qu'on nomme
au ministère des affaires européennes un
responsable politique parlementaire qui
a eu des positions très claires sur un
certain nombre d'actes qu'elle ait pu
poser l'union et puis très vite parce
que l'europe c'est une mécanique c'est
une et camille comprend des positions où
on rencontre des acteurs j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expliquer que le non de
2005 était pas un anti européen c'était
un nom d'espérance ont une autre europe
et j'ai eu l'occasion d'expliquer autour
de la table dès 27 que ce que nous
étions en train de faire la croissance
la taxe sur les transactions financières
la supervision bancaire
c'était précisément ce pour quoi nous
nous étions reflet passé devient
finalement des atouts aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas c'est pas ce que nous ne
voulions pas d'hier
nous sommes en train de le corriger aux
réglages c'est quand même extrêmement
intéressant quand on est en politique et
qu'on s'est battus pour quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas réussi à obtenir de
pouvoir essayer de l'obtenir en étant
dans l'exercice du pouvoir le pouvoir ça
consiste à un moment donné à prendre des
sujets difficiles sur lesquels on prend
des risques et d'essayer de faire en
sorte de tendre vers l'objectif auquel
on croit c'est ce que je fais pas
d'habileté là dans une sincérité absolue
et ma vie politique qui est encore
courte et qui déjà beaucoup plus longue
qu'elle ne le sera demain
est une vie politique où je me suis
constamment engagé avec sincérité et
passion sur les choses et vous avez tous
vous avez aussi à la rencontre de nos
gros de nos grand pardon européen je
pense à jacques delorme chalard valéry
giscard d'estaing ça c'est les
rencontres que vous avez fait aussi à
votre nomination
qu'est ce que vous recherchez conseil
auprès de l'un des gens cherchaient pas
de conseils je cherchais à comprendre
cherché à savoir
je cherchais à relier les fils de
l'action qui avait été la leur hier
l'action que nous conduisons aujourd'hui
moi je ne crois pas que healy comme
d'autres ont pu le penser à certaines
occasions des ruptures qui permettent
d'organiser à chaque interne ans des
grands soirs je ne pensais peut-être le
plus marquant que vous avez retenu de
ces entretiens aller avec tout ce qui
suit non non quand même leur nom mais
j'ai surtout vécu des moments émouvants
à l'occasion avec beaucoup d acteurs qui
avait rencontré sont des amis qui ont
une grande expérience qui ont
aujourd'hui il ya un âge certain
tandis que valéry giscard d'estaing à
l'appliquer la manière dont il
conduisait ses relations avec helmut
schmidt lorsqu'à l'occasion du déjeuner
avec jacques delors qui titre d'une
acuité sur les sujets qu'ils
connaissaient tous les mécanismes
européens comme s'il était encore aux
affaires m'expliquer le lien qui
existait entre ce qu'il avait cherché à
construire
est ce que nous essayons de faire
aujourd'hui vous rendez compte de
l'enrichissement pour moi qui a râlé
danse est responsable et qui était
d'ailleurs très admiratif de coûts
combat mené par ces grands acteurs
européens
alors bernard cazenave ya une question
qui nous arrive de notre partenaire
orange c'est l'application tvcheck une
question de antoine comment vous allez
aux électeurs réagissent à la tenue
d'une conférence sur l'environnement
peut-être rappeler qu'effectivement vous
êtes élue d'une circonscription qu'on
présente souvent comme la plus atomique
en france parce qu'il y ait à la fois à
l'usiné de la hague et les in de
flamanville 1 écoutez je n'ai pas fait
le sondage vous en faites vos coûts déjà
je vais pas en faire de plus je pense
que non mais beaucoup beaucoup de
de ceux qui vivent dans les régions où
l'activité nucléaire profondément
pourvoyeur d'emplois souhaite bien
entendu que le nucléaire continue à
avoir une place dans le panel bande
magnétique français oui moi c'est une
position que j'ai toujours eue je pense
qu'il est important que nucléaire garde
une place dans la donne énergétique
français parce que il permet d'avoir un
prix de l'énergie un deal en carbone qui
est un atout pour la france
ce qui n'empêche pas de continuer ce qui
ne m'empêche pas de considérer que le
président de la république a raison de
vouloir réorienter la politique
énergétique parce que ce qui fera la
force de la france c'est d'avoir un
bouquet énergétique le plus diversifié
possible ce que nous avons fait sur le
nucléaire nous devons être capables de
le faire sur le renouvelable nous devons
être capables de le faire sur l'éco
construction nous devons être capables
de le faire en terme d'économie
d'énergie
donc la france sera plus forte si elle a
un bouquet énergétique diversifiée si
les énergies nouvelles font de
l'industrie sur le territoire national
parce que nous avons besoin de
réindustrialiser donc ya pas de double
langage du gouvernement c'est
l'accusation ce soir sur notre site
publicsenat.fr de noël mamère à propos
du nucléaire mais il y a un discours du
gouvernement qui est équilibré nous
n'avons jamais préconisé la sortie du
nucléaire nous avons préconisé une
diminution du la part du nucléaire dans
le panel énergétique français pour
assurer le développement des énergies
renouvelables des énergies de demain
nous avons dit que nous le ferions en
accompagnant les groupes industriels qui
s'engageraient dans cette voie tout en
garantissant le maintien d'une activité
nucléaire dont nous avons besoin
est-ce qu'il faut limiter l'interdiction
du cumul des mandats aux sénateurs non
je pense que le cumul des mandats
s'applique à tout le monde
personne pourtant jeu qui est bien mais
pas énormément je n'aime pas des signaux
collectivités territoriales a demandé
mon avis maintenant là encore on est
dans un processus
il ya une commission qui a été mise en
place par
le président de la république et qui est
confié à lyonnaise donc avant de parler
d'exception de nous régaler dis
simplement qu'il faut je ne sais même
pas d'ailleurs si cette exception
pourrait s'agir et constitutionnel je
pense que la question du cumul des
mandats doit être abordée en recherchant
le plus grand consensus possible entre
les formations politiques
en même temps il ya un engagement du
président de la république le président
de la république a dit souhaiter mettre
en oeuvre cet engagement il a confié à
lionel jospin le soin de faire dans la
convention en laissant cette procédure
accomplir tranquillement et ne tend pas
sur des sujets de ce type il est
tellement la corrèze sur l' affaire
karachi on vous a vu intervenir à deux
reprises en dans le sujet la cour
d'appel de paris a validé hier le volet
financier de l'enquêté
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'on
va connaître un jour la vérité dans
cette affaire il faut se battre pour la
vérité
moi je continuerai à le faire parce que
les liens que j'ai avec cherbourg les
familles piech avons souffert avec ce
territoire qui m'a beaucoup donné sont
indestructibles et que j'estime comme un
devoir moral ou de continuer en bas
d'ailleurs est un sujet sur lequel le
président de la république a pris des
engagements et sur lequel nous restons
mobilisés c'est la question de la
protection statutaire pour que les
familles des victimes puissent
bénéficier de cette protection pouvoir
financer leurs frais de justice qui leur
permettront d'accéder à la vérité sur
l'anc est surmontée par exemple de la
levée du secret défense président de la
république a pris l'engagement que il
aura une et christie fication d'être
totalité des documents demandés par les
juges vous savez que la procédure secret
défense est encadré le juge demande la
commission consultative du secret de la
défense nationale se prononce les miss
et classifie pour ce qui concerne les
demandes nouvelles formulées par les
juges le président de la république
indiqué qu'il y aurait une
déclassification totale et cet
engagement sera tenu grand quand il
justement dans le document il reste 30
secondes on a évoqué votre vos liens
d'amitié à la fois avec laurent fabius
et françois hollande vous êtes le seul
socialiste à avoir fait comme ça la
jonction
donc si vous voulez moi je le refais
abus je lui dois tout en politique c'est
avec lui que j'ai appris les choses et
il a été un extraordinaire mentor et
rien qui sont très anciens que j'ai avec
lui il ya là aussi indestructible
françois hollande je le rencontre au
début des années 90 il y a eu
spontanément une relation amicale de
confiance et à mesure que le temps passe
et nous nous sommes vus de plus en plus
c'est cette relation s'est renforcée
voilà je je n'ai pas donné
d'explications mais ils s'aiment
beaucoup n'arrivent pas à le montrer
bah non de vous avez tort ils sont dix
travaillent de façon très étroite avec
l'autre laurent fabius joue un rôle
extrêmement important dans ce
gouvernement sondage est compliqué et il
écrit qu'il à françois hollande et
françois hollande a besoin de laurent
cuisine le pouvoir change lors de ses
récents efforts
merci à vous ce qu'elle-même merci
perrine bonsoir à tous et la semaine
prochaine françois rebsamen
le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat sera notre invité il ne partage
pas du tout votre sentiment sur le cumul
des mandats
à bientôt